[Music]
lisa
is with us in tampa florida hi lisa how
are you
um hi dave and rachel hope you're having
a blessed day
we are how can we help yeah um i um
my i'm not 60 and my husband is two
and uh we've been fpu coordinators i
could do a commercial for you for about
seven years
thank you and it's been such a blessing
to us and
you know i can testify we've seen lives
changed really forever
and because of your teachings my husband
and i are heading into retirement
looking pretty darn good
and we had a 15-year mortgage and our
house was going to
be paid off six and a half years early
next year
yay it's awesome so i'm so excited about
that
um but as we're heading into retirement
this is my question dave
i have two very dear friends who have um
have pointed me in the direction i'm
interviewing two financial advisors
and they have very different opinions um
you know with us being 60 one says a
trust is good the other says i wouldn't
do a trust if you have beneficiaries and
one says well let's put some of your
money into annuities and the other one
says i don't like annuities
because right now my money a lot of it's
in the stock market and um we're just
looking to get
a little you know different opinion and
maybe get a little
some of it a little less aggressive so
what do you think
um are either one of them smart vester
pros
i don't know if they are well then
they're not
my friends recommended them and they're
not okay so the first thing i would tell
you is get a third opinion
and that's get with the smartvestor pro
one off our website
and that's not just to send you the to
them for business that's not the point
the point is what you're running into is
a philosophical problem that the
financial world has
and the financial world is taught to be
arrogant
they're taught to tell you what to do
because you don't have a brain
and then roll their eyes in a sense if
you don't do it
instead what we teach you and you know
this from financial peace university is
your job as the owner of the money the
manager of the money for god
is to get someone with the heart of a
teacher
and then you learn what the options are
and i don't care what they say
you have enough information that you
decided based on the
information you gathered whether this is
right for you
so what is your net worth um
we have saved now about 750 000
excellent i don't know why you would
need any annuities
in that personally okay
yes the only advantage that the annuity
gives you is the the variable annuity
gives you
is it can give you a guarantee of
principle if the market turns down
and it can give you a guaranteed floor
on the rate of return
but as you know from financial peace
university we don't teach variable
annuities
unless your house is paid off unless
everything's maxed out
and then unless you are really worried
about
one of those two things inordinately
worried about it because you're going to
pay an extra fee for the annuity
and your money's going to be trapped yet
again and so
the what i didn't like about it's going
to be trapped yeah again
it was to start with in retirement and
now it's trapped again and so i don't
i'm 60 i don't have a dime in annuities
because i'm very comfortable with market
fluctuations i'm very comfortable with
principal fluctuations on my accounts
they're not going to make or break me
they're not going to make or break you
you're millionaires
uh and you're going to do fine okay so
that that
i i do utilize trusts but only for
estate planning purposes
because my net worth is in excess of 25
million dollars and that's the only time
you get
into net worth issues with estate
planning
meaning the federal estate tax does not
kick in until then
okay so i've had to utilize some of them
and i'm also using them
in a couple of places just for risk
management
and the last piece i'm using a trust for
is the transfer of this company to the
kids
is it true what he says though about the
um
the trust that um that if you have
beneficiaries you don't really need a
trust
well you the it depends on what you're
using the trust for
you can use a trust for saving money on
estate taxes you don't need it for that
you can use a trust to execute your
wishes if you have beneficiaries in a
will
you don't need it for that right the
only thing it could save you
uh you're in what state florida i don't
think you've got
much of a probate tax in florida i don't
remember but that your state probate tax
it might save you a little bit on that
it's not worth the cost of the hassle to
run your life out of a trust i wouldn't
do it
right so two strikes yeah two strikes
against whoever said those two annuity
and i didn't yeah but the point is
the point is i want you to get with
somebody where you
learn and you're not even doing what
dave ramsey says
you're doing what lisa knows to do and
rachel it's just so important to get
your hands around you and winston make
your own decisions you don't come ask me
what to do
no in fact i tried to ask you once
you're like you guys could figure it out
i was like no really tell me tell me
what to do
but no there there's something really
truly about
understanding the entire process and
sitting down and doing that and like he
said but it's true like
that you make the decision that you're
comfortable with because the moment you
start to be uncomfortable
is when is when i think anxiousness
comes in right some anxiety and like oh
i don't know about the future did i make
the right decision to be confident in
the decision george told me
about the facts yeah and i don't ever
want to care what george told me
so even with a you know a medical doctor
sharon makes fun of me because i
question him i question everybody it's
like you need to tell me why you're
doing this
i'm not gonna just trust you because you
got a white coat you know
you gotta tell me why we're doing what
we're doing a lawyer this is the way to
go okay
why you're you know i'm giving you a lot
of money here
to teach me why i'm gonna take this
legal action and i think the reason
people
don't is it's intimidating to to admit
hey i don't i don't know what's going on
so i feel safer
just saying you just take care of it
okay okay right digging into all the
details it's intimidating but you have
to to be able to get the answers you
you need and you want for your life well
you don't have peace if you don't
if you don't make the decision you'll
get peace if someone else makes your
decisions you don't get peace
and you don't get the results on the
extreme this is how these athletes lose
all their money these actors lose all
their money
they give it to a guy and then they go
where'd my hundred million dollars go i
have no money
because the guy screwed off with the
money you know freaking bernie madoff or
something right
and so you don't turn your money you
earned
over to someone else you use them to
teach you and you make the decision they
might implement it with you
because they brought a good idea and
that's your financial person right
but you don't put money in something you
don't understand and lisa you you're
gonna do great with this
you've done so good i'm so proud of you
millionaires way to go
everyday millionaires right there
talking to them and teaching fpu seven
of the years that's awesome man
very very